Kurt Sutter's a mixed sons of anarchy
for those who don't know and what
watching what he's done as as very much
an employee of news court telling story
is that he he makes a show called what
the Sutter and he answers questions
about the show and he talks about the
making the show
and someone asked him why he did that
and he said I only have a show for three
months you know like 13 episodes so 13
weeks and then
there's no show so he keeps the audience
talking all right from the end in
December they go into pre-production
like now birdy you know it shows season
six already pitched so he's already
talking about the making of it and then
in this past season he had a crew that
made a before the anarchy making Oh
series so he was generating content
about the content before there was
content and after there was contact and
I started looking at vampire mob because
i believe all these bloopers I had an a
bunch of people would ask me questions
online and I'm like I literally shoot it
with my phone
and I ask four questions on Twitter I'll
give away like a t-shirt or a poster and
so I started talking about vampire mode
and now we make the show and I joked on
Twitter once if I ever have another show
that it called coffee and swearing
because that's what I talk about and
it's where a lot so so then that became
this great I kind of spiked the interest
in the show because they the audience
you know would write a question i would
type it it would roll up on screen and a
little sudden conversation was different
something about because they would see
me and answer and they'd see my cat and
it was something more human about it and
so I'm like I'm just gonna rip off Kurt
Sutter I'm gonna make coffee and
swearing and I thought that was gonna
kind of go into the making the vampire
mob and then behind the scenes of
vampire them off so what partying
swearing I'm looking at now is kind of
my like almost like a video blog a to
say like that but it's it's honestly
it's going to be whatever the I
want it to be but it will be kind of
bounced off whatever project I'm working
on so I'm going to do one more episode
on the vampire mob channel and then the
loop of the play shorts
I'll do co-op inspiring about play
shorts about fundraising behind the
scenes making them and then if I can
come back to making another season
vampire mob I can move the show back to
that channel or whatever the next thing
is going to be there always have
something so watching somebody like
groups that are tweeting doing qas on
Twitter it taught me to think about how
to make content about the content that
I'm and I am making stories about the
stories I know I don't know I'm just I'm
just saying in this context i'm using
content about London but it is behind
the scenes about because the people he
who like the honeyed seeing stuff and
all that it's not everybody the people
who watch a coffee swearing it's really
the hardcore people so much I get that
out of my head like my friends aren't
gonna watch this they talk to me they
don't give a they're not gonna
watch me talking and answering questions
I can we talk on the phone so kit I got
those people out of my head because I
talk to somebody else I'm like you
should make like I'm making out like I
know I do that what am I gonna talk
about like I'm worried about what people
are gonna think in like what what are
you be worried about what people like
the press stop like don't even ask you
comment delete it like just so so yeah
it's if everything is the story like I
feel like my Instagram is a story it
goes twitter as a story I feel like
comin swearing is a story it's all its
stories about making the stories it's
sort of like my story about being an
infinite storyteller like that's part of
story it's all one big thing I don't
look as a little project and I can catch
some I'll be back here a little tiny bit
of allama ok and I think that's the that
seems like more fun it seems like a
better business plan seems more
sustainable seems more humid seems like
it's not Industrial Revolution
he's still working on your food a little
bit ok yeah or the awards are trying to
please people while they're trying to
get you know when somebody says ah you
know I was sick in bed and I was
watching vampire mom and it made me
laugh thank you that's like I'm sorry
but that like that's enough to keep me
going for a long time
and people have watched it more than
once and yeah when when when people say
oh I thought a vampire mob today because
they said rectify the situation they
remember the line from something or you
know the dog in the show gets a
Christmas present from here oh yes you
know that's human that's that's real
that's not demographics and sponsors and
validation and
all the bull like we don't need the
we just all we need to do is
tell stories and we don't need to tell
on someone's schedule we just need to
get enough money to sustain ourselves to
tell the stories and to keep going and
that's gonna build and it's going to
build real like interest really
but it keeps it alive
you